so as we continue with the Age of
Apocalypse what we do now is take a look
at the world as it exists at the moment
that is to say how the world's been
shaped now that apocalypse rules North
America and the reason why is because a
lot of you have been asking questions
about not just Magneto's plan some of
the characters that we've seen but how
the world's changed what the world looks
like now how the territories are divvied
up what happened to the Avengers where
are Captain America Iron Man and all
those two main characters where
spider-man is stuff at all this and so
we're going to answer that question in
this video the continental United States
itself seems to be where apocalypse
focuses most of his efforts and divvying
up territories among his four horsemen
the states of Washington Oregon Idaho
Nevada Utah Arizona California New
Mexico and half of Montana belonged to
Holocaust with San Francisco as the
capital of this territory the Holocaust
was a character that had appeared before
the Age of Apocalypse but didn't really
achieve any publication of any real kind
until Adriel pocalypse started the
Holocaust is actually a character called
nemesis but it's not clear if this is
the same nemesis that is the son of
cable or if it's if it's a different
version what we do know here though is
that Holocaust as he exists in the Age
of Apocalypse is the appearance son of
Apocalypse himself and the glowing body
that you see with Holocaust is actually
a suit that he wears let's compose of
bio nuclear energy that allows him
longevity near invulnerability and the
ability to fire the sort of bio nuclear
energy blasts at people now the states
of North Dakota South Dakota Nebraska
Kansas Wyoming Colorado and the other
half of Montana pretty much the upper
half of middle America this entire
territory belongs to Mikhail Rasputin
now Mikhail Rasputin is the brother of
Colossus and what we know is that
Mikhail Rasputin powers at least what it
is East capable of doing are in truth
ambiguous at best because Marvel's never
really explain them to us I've never
really told us here's the defined list
of what it is that Mikhail Rasputin can
do but what we know is that when
apocalypse began his conquest of the
world that Mikhail Rasputin alongside
Colossus were able to hold off
apocalypses forces when apocalypse
attempted to invade Russia
now this ultimately led to apocalypse
kidnapping and brainwashing Mikael
Rasputin and turning him into one of his
four horsemen but at this point in the
story and what we'll find is things
progress is that Mikhail Rasputin so it
begins to walk this middle ground where
he kind of begins to deviate away from
the path of apocalypse and sort of begin
to take on its own mantle and try try to
attend his own conquest of Europe
entirely now the next group of states
are basically like the lower middle
America and some of Mexico they are
Oklahoma Texas and the upper part of
Mexico and they're controlled by a
character named abyss now this is an
extremely minor character in the Age of
Apocalypse with his only real
achievement being one of apocalypses
horsemen that's really it we don't
really know much about abyss at all in
fact he was created for the Age of
Apocalypse itself what we do know is
that he's somehow related to
Nightcrawler and that he has the ability
to feed on the fear of others in order
to power himself but again we're not
going to find out much about him we're
really only going to see him maybe
engage in a few conflicts and that's
really it we don't really even know why
apocalypse made him a horseman in the
first place now the states of Wisconsin
Iowa Missouri Minnesota Illinois Indiana
Arkansas and Louisiana all belong to mr.
sinister in terms of mr. sinister in the
Age of Apocalypse as we discussed in our
first video sinister is the right-hand
man of apocalypse and it's also
responsible for overseeing the genetic
manipulation of humans and mutants by
dark beasts what we'll also find out
though is that as time progresses mr.
sinister actually has his own agenda he
has his own plans to attempt to
overthrow the I guess overthrow the rule
of apocalypse by creating a being using
the DNA of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
this character will become known as Nate
grey or x-man and so this is going to
play a major role when we get towards
the end of this conflict and we find out
there are some characters after the Age
of Apocalypse ends that actually survive
on into the earth-616 universe by
basically jumping ship
by jumping through this reality and into
a new one now all the other states that
we haven't listed here that are part of
the of the continental United States
that is to say the main portion of the
United States not including outlying
territories like Hawaii all these states
belong to apocalypse this is
all just his main territory right here
now at this point we jump to the rest of
the world the Central American
territories that connect North America
to South America had basically been
completely eliminated and Marvel doesn't
really give us an answer as to why this
was done is presumed that it was done in
order to create this kind of boundary
this kind of territory that basically
keeps North America safe from all the
other territories around it that
basically provides us kind of protection
zone but model doesn't really give us an
answer to this and in truth I wouldn't
go as far as to say that it's really
important enough that we get an answer
here but what we do know is that most of
South America is referred to as the
atrocity zone and that Brazil was
totally destroyed it was totally
eliminated by a nuclear attack and what
it did was it basically created this
emanating wave of radiation that began
to spread throughout South America and
so the result was that it's believed
that some measure of the population from
South America was able to escape by
fleeing to either Europe and Asia or
Antarctica now the black line that you
see on this map here that looks kind of
like a directional path is referred to
as the infernal galop and it's actually
a sort of underground railroad system
that's ran by mystique and leads to a
place called Avalon in Antarctica the
location referred to as Avalon is
actually the Savage Land and this is
kind of a lush jungle environment that
operates as a refuge for both humans and
mutants
when apocalypse first launched his
conquest many of the humans and mutants
of North America fled to either Avalon
Europe or Asia and so while Avalon
itself is known to apocalypse and his
forces it also stands under the
protection of Cain Marko who has the
power of the juggernaut like his
earth-616 version but isn't the villain
he's not really a bad guy here instead
he's actually the personal bodyguard of
a blind clairvoyant named destiny who
can see into the future and so what
we're going to find is that with her
character and when we get into the plan
of magneto in our next video we're going
to find that nightcrawlers actually
assign the task to travel to Avalon to
find destiny and then bring destiny
towards or bring destiny to magneto now
from here we jump to Europe and Asia and
this is where we find a brunt of the
forces that are non mutants so those of
you guys who are curious about the
Avengers about spider-man about all
those to make characters this is what
you're going to learn what all's been
going on here when the various humans of
mutants again fled for North
America many of them travel to Europe in
Asia and from there the established
governments that currently existed at
the time were cast off entirely and in
their place the human High Council was
established the human High Council as it
exists and the Age of Apocalypse is led
by ball of our Trask and more attracts
more McTaggart basically who married
ball of our Trask and it actually guards
all the territories outside of North
America and Avalon which includes Africa
which presumably includes New Zealand it
includes Greenland those kind of places
those territories but again outside of
Europe and Asia and parts of Africa
we're not really given an explanation in
terms of how the human High Council
works in those territories and so what
we find here is that in addition to all
of our Trask and more attracts but there
are also other high-ranking members that
exist directly under them and these
members include Brian Braddock who
actually did not become Captain Britain
Emma Frost whose powers of telepathy
were removed by virtue of lobotomy and
Victor Von Doom who never became Doctor
Doom in addition to this general
Thunderbolt Ross actually leads a team
is composed of Clint Barton Carol
Danvers who never became Captain Marvel
Susan storm who never became the
Invisible Woman and Ben Grimm who never
became the thing and all these
individuals are basically they're are
normal human versions with the Fantastic
Four they never actually travelled into
space and they were never exposed to
cosmic radiation but for Johnny Storm
and Reed Richards what had actually
happened with them is that very early on
they had been killed off they were
killed during the callings er in the
attempts to get humans out of North
America and to safety in Europe in
addition to this gwen stacy is alive and
she's actually part of the human high
council operating alongside Donald Blake
who had never become Thor Peter Parker
who was believed to have been a contact
of when Stacy's was actually killed off
in the early callings black panther was
killed off in Wakanda due to the fact
that apocalypse had basically raided the
vibranium stores in Wakanda and because
white panther was loved by his people so
much they killed him and then strung his
body up so that as I guess serve as kind
of a warning so that if anybody showed
up that was attending to basically cast
off the forces of apocalypse they would
they would meet the same fate as Black
Panther
but we also know here is that the human
High Council employs various mercenaries
at their disposal and two of these
mercenaries are Jean Grey and Wolverine
and so what we'll find is when we get
into the next video again talking about
the plans of magneto and the plans of
the human High Council
we'll find out the human High Council is
actually prepared to basically go to
nuclear war with North America in order
to stave off the advancements of
apocalypse as he attempts to expand his
conquests for the rest of the world and
that Jean Grey and Wolverine will play a
major part in this story with that being
said we're going to go ahead and ring
this video to and I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace what's
life like to make it on the fans of a
day Oh make it home identify whose
birthday cake this right here disorder
ever known bring so much travel to take
boys let the noxious because I'm get
playdough so a little assess wrap it up
or lass to prove I know segue reveal a
sublimable rights of a brain not quite
ironic though free to drop sections on
the race to find a pound for every
barber bet they'll be filthy rich